trente ans de réclusion criminelle pour
séquestration détention et privations
ayant entraîné la mort c'est la peine
infligée à la seule femme accusée lors
de ce procès les jurés ont donc décidé
de ne pas suivre la réquisition de
l'avocat général qui réclamait la
perpétuité une peine finalement allégé
pour celle qui est à l'origine des actes
de torture et de la mort de nicolas
laporte et que les experts dépeignent
comme tyrannique
la femme de 52 ans et son avocat sont
soulagés c'est une décision juste et
équilibrée puisqu'elle permet à ma
cliente de d'avoir l'espoir de voir ses
enfants et c'est vrai qu'avec un désir
de ses enfants qui est accusée dans la
même affaire je crois que les
perspectives de retrouvailles même dans
un lointain délai c'est utile et
nécessaire pour tout le monde
trente ans également pour l'oncle de
nicolas laporte qui a participé
activement à la torture du jeune homme
entre octobre 2011 et janvier 2012 et
même conservé un enregistrement sonore
insoutenable du calvaire de la victime
l'amant de la principal accusé écope lui
de 28 en prison des peines lourdes mais
juste selon la famille de nicolas
laporte
je suis contente parce que ça fait
quatre ans que ça dure c'est très dur
psychologiquement physiquement j'étais
soulagé
tout à fait je trouve que dans
l'ensemble c'est une décision équilibrée
et qui restitue à chacun le rôle qu'il a
eu enfin le rôle qu'il a eue là prennent
l'eau chez moi je trouve que c'est un
jugement sévère mais équipe l'ami du
groupe qui a participé au transport du
corps de nicolas laporte pour être jetés
dans un canal écope de deux ans de
prison dont un avec sursis
quant au fils de la principale accusée
qui n'avait que 17 ans au moment des
faits
les jurés ont retenu l'altération du
jugement et l'excusé de minorité
pour lui ce sera 10 ans d'emprisonnement
je crois quand on a 21 ans
c'est la fin du monde mais rapporté au
fait ça reste ce qu'on peut appeler la
juste peine
les brodeuses nicolas laporte
rejoindront dès ce soir la maison
d'arrêt de nevers leur meneuse quand
elle poursuivra sa détention à bourges
durant 15 ans au minimum
les avocats de la défense ont désormais
dix jours pour faire appel de ces
décisions